[Musik]
habe ich von andys der
polizeihauptmeister chocri in kairo und
dies ist der polizeihauptmeister pepa
calimera galibier calamari horst ist
ja schön dass sie wieder dabei sind bei
einer neuen ausgabe von die polizei lebt
ja und wir sind auch dabei ja aber das
ist ja ja aber gestern werden wir nicht
dabei gewesen weil da war ich noch in
griechenland und du in italien hd stimmt
und mit unserem frisch gesammelten
wissen möchten wie sie heute athen zone
informieren über die abgezockten
touristenort socken im ausland genau
aber wenn man die augen offen hält und
über einen messerscharfen verstand
verfügt kann schon nicht mehr viel
schiefgehen
sowie im rittergut ja von mir sehr
schwer dieses unglaubliche schnäppchen
habe ich am strand von griechenland
gemacht
und wo hast du darfst dir echt ist
freilich ist die ich da steht doch drauf
messerscharfer verstand schüssen
homestead
abgeschworen und außerdem wer hat sich
denn am markusplatz in venedig einen
kaffee für 20 euro bestellt hatte für 20
euro ich bin doch nicht blöd 19 89 oder
kosten dann hast du ja sauber runter
gehandelt erzählt die geschichte und
einem espresso krämer studiert haben
überhaupt nichts zur sache da habe ich
meine augen in die cafés wird er hat
meint ist wie ein espresso gräber
[Gelächter]
19 eur 89 fx da lob ich mir griechenland
das ist preislich noch total in ordnung
12 eur 50 für einen fischteller poseidon
da kann man nicht meckern du hast du
gewusst dass in griechenland grüne
calamares gibt es gibt es doch grüne
calamares freilich das ist eine
spezialität hat dimitri gesagt du hast
so edwards essen habe ich danach im
krankenhaus nicht mehr bekommen
weil ich schon die sich aber gründlich
in die hose gegangen ja aber auch schon
oben raus wie auch immer ich hoffe wir
konnten ihnen wieder wertvolle tipps an
die hand geben das im urlaub eine
unbeschwerte zeit verbringen können
schönen urlaub
[Applaus]
[Musik]